[Applause]
ukrainians gather outside the irish
parliament to hear their president
address a joint sitting of both houses
russia is using this hunger weapon
it's the latest national parliament to
hear the ukrainian president's message a
call for more action against russia
mixed with gratitude
thank you for the humanitarian and
financial support
extended to our country and thank you
for your
caring
about ukrainian people who found shelter
on your land
outside his compatriots gave their
reaction at the moment he's my president
we had many differences when he got
elected but for the time being i think
all ukrainians are behind our president
and he's doing his job and i'm and i'm
proud what he's done
and that seems to be a common theme many
ukrainians here told us they didn't vote
for zolensky some said they found it
hard to take him seriously when he was
first elected but they're not saying
that now
mother and daughter gana and paulina are
trying to make a new home in dublin
after fleeing keith
it was a strong speech i think
and
one month ago
we just joked at him
he is a former comedian
and nobody uh even thought that he would
be a good politician but now
he does well
his speeches are strong
he uh
speaks very um from his heart from his
heart i think he's like kind of hero
right because he talked to our people
every day
uh he
encouraged us he always said that we
will win we will win and we believe also
he stays in kiev it's very important for
people
they may not all have voted for him and
they already knew what he was going to
say but today their president spoke on
the international stage once more and
made them feel that bit closer to home
stephen murphy sky news dublin